it's worth reflecting that one of the
early signs that we're facing a real
problem with the pandemic actually came
from markets back in february you can
probably see what happened to the ftse
100 it's the main index of shares
in the uk just look at how much it fell
now that in a way prefigured what
what happened later so the lockdown and
so on that was an early
signal of what was to come so it is
worth focusing on the fact that now
we have perhaps the first convincing
signs of a coveted bounce
in markets and what i'll do is i'll just
zoom into the past week that's
that's going back the past year let me
zoom into the past week so you can see
last monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday and
then we've got today and look at today
so actually early on
in the morning at the start of trading
there was a bit of an increase some
people have put that down to the
confirmation of joe biden
becoming president-elect and then look
what happens at
11 30. so when that vaccine was
announced so you had a very big increase
up by about
four percent in the following seconds
and it's not just the uk look at
different
stock markets around the world so this
shows you the ftse 100 up
uh the higher these are the the bigger
the increase on the day 5100 up by about
four point seven percent the cat come on
that's the french market
up by about uh getting off eight percent
uh the dax in germany up by about five
percent and the dow jones
up by four percent and other people have
watched this
including donald trump he's obviously
reflected on different stock market
changes recently
uh and here you can see his tweet just
after this stock market up big vaccine
coming soon report 90
effective such great news but let's just
dig into which companies fared
best because it gives you a sense of
which sectors have uh
are most relieved about this certain
news the possibility of life returning
back to normal iag that's the owner of
british airways up by
uh the most in the ftse 100. in former
uh they're involved
in conferences british land that's kind
of a reflection of what's going on
uh in the property market so maybe
offices and so on compass
they've got catering and then land
security so you're getting a sense of
different parts of the stock market and
why they have reacted to this
they're hoping that things do return to
normal but let's reflect too
uh on this compared with other days so
this these bars show you
the biggest daily increases over the
past five years and what you can see is
look
this was the second biggest one-day
increase uh
in the uk stock market in the 5100 that
we've seen over the past half decade
it's worth reflecting too that when you
look at the and what i've done is
highlighted the ones that have happened
this year around the coronavirus
pandemic so many of them
have come this year a reminder just how
much volatility there still is
in the stock market